our last
speaker
yes
professor bingy
i
don't think i need to do a long
introduction because everyone here knows
professor bing
for her work which expands a lot of
fields including
statics machine learning
data science
neuroscience
genomics so today
professor yi is going to talk about
adaptive wavelet distillation from
neural networks the floor is yours thank
you
thank you for the organizers to having
me here and
so i welcome questions during the talk
so just interrupt me and
so what i want to talk here is really
um define like the most recent work
on this line of interpretation learning
and i'd like to start a little earlier
too
from the history of how we get where we
are
so i think a lot of you probably know
for trustworthy ai
and in general intervention learning is
at the frontier and eu has this for five
years now data protection regulation
really gives the right to explanation so
this is really make it like
a customer can actually request the
acronym say patient for your item to be
interpretable
and just
these are the problems i have
encountered i was at the ipam workshop i
think couple years ago and
ceo of a start-up was talking to me
about intervention learning because fda
was asking her company to provide
interpretable
interpretation for her deep learning
algorithms when we work with biologists
we try to figure out
like false orders third other interacts
different genes for making
the fate of a cell
and you will see example from cosmology
and also sentiment analysis from machine
learning
and i think euros also started very well
in the earlier talk i would call
scientific machine learning
that i defined it the term has been used
but it's my definition it uses machine
learning for scientific research to
extract from data discoveries theory and
knowledge
and view scientific principles
especially like symmetry things like
that from physics emotional algorithms
and also we hope we do new science so it
iterates between the two steps and we
think the results should be subject to
higher standards of scientific standards
than user machine learning standards
about three or four years ago i have
different people jamie chandan reese and
carl working on different aspects
machine interpretation learning and we
finally decided even within my group we
need to agree on what do we mean by
interpretation learning so that's what
we came up with the paper two years ago
we defined interval machine learning as
extraction relevant knowledge from
machine learning model concerning
relationship either containing data or
learned by the model
here we view knowledge as being relevant
so this is something we want to
emphasize
if we apply insight for particular
audience we're bringing human into this
consideration interpretation is not for
another machine it's for some group of
humans and to a chosen problem the
interpretation could be different if you
use even the same machinery for
different purposes and there's a goal
which is to guide communication actions
and discovery so we want to really
ground it
to something
more
tangible than just like pretty high
level qualitative
so we develop this predictive accuracy
descriptive accuracy and rather
relevancy paradigm
so say you need people
you need a problem
and you need reality checks to predict
accuracy
descriptor accuracy is kind of
more qualitative even the five authors
took us a long time to agree on uh
uh definition so i won't get any detail
to it because this is really about
adaptive wavelets and just give you
that's mostly people think right uh you
have decision trees legit regulation
deep learning is the most black box we
know
and the generic interpretability people
agree that you want sparse you don't
want too many complex models
and mutability is very important the
human can follow the algorithm and
really
know how the decision is made decision
trees small decisions are perfect for
that
and decomposibility modularity so what
do i would talk about about domain
specific interval features
credit score right we all have credit
scores there's a bunch of things about
our financial behavior mixed into now is
meaningful
for here
coefficients physics
and wavelengths local field transform so
these things are very domain specific
and a lot of the machine learning work
can really give new interval features
later domain scientists will embrace and
can use it and make it
for their scientific work and validate
it
and post how interpretability that's
also what i'm discussing is the model is
already fitted i'm not feeding the model
there's another aspect how do you make
the fitting interval that's not what i'm
talking about it's about fitting model
how do you interpret you can go by p
values versus huge significance this
global
interval quantities
and you can also go to local level
and i think in scientific machine
learning
relevance is the key right
so the insights we get from these
machine learning models have to
correspond to facts about the real world
and the interpretation machine animal
needs to be valid and calibrated against
trustworthy step factual information so
this is
not just for the
fun of oh i can interpret it but really
this interpretation has to be valid
so for the rest of the talk i'll talk
about a precursor to awd it's earlier
work sequence of conference papers
compared with other competitors what we
were able to do is give important to
group features you can study
interactions
and then we end up doing
really group it's a huge transform to go
to a free domain but still a group in
some sense
and then when you do fourier it's
natural to us how about a wavelet so
that's how end up is adaptive
distillation and the problem motivated
was the cosmology project entry um
and then we also did a cell biology
project so the
algorithm narrative contextual
decomposition acd
go beyond the gradient integration for
pixel to talk about importance of blocks
of pixels
so this is a quick summary like the
gradient base it's still it's all
of perturbation greetings infinite
testimony perturbation
and you can do bigger perturbation
occlusion and sharp and our method falls
into the second category
i'll go very quickly because this is
just to say that we started with
sentiment analysis is pretty not
scientific
and you want to give
importance not just to knowledge and
good but also not good so this is a
combination of features
and
we were able to decompose deep learning
in
additive way to distribute
all this
prediction
at different layers to the relevant bits
and the irrelevant bit so this is just
to give you we basically take
the image the company two part and trace
how the relevant part
interact with different parts i made it
additive and we have scores
and with the scores it's pretty
disorganized so in this acd paper
we made it organized we're saying that
hey you see that the reason not very
good is negative
in the beginning very good all positive
it's the not the last stage
so we merge these
entities using the cd scores to make the
biggest jump of the cd score and we do
hierarchical clustering and can do also
for
images and we did two small human
experiments to show that our method are
favorable
and this thing
can be followed up
and then we also feedback the acd score
you know this is icml paper
to decrease so human knows that your
algorithm
depends on gender so for loan
approval
and you can
now put a penalty depends on score with
human embedded information i want the
dependence on gender to be low
and therefore
remove some bias in the algorithm
okay so here's what i really want to
talk about
so this is really a project actually now
i was also part of this
tripod
and toward the end of um
francois who also worked with eures
i started talking to him oh now you're
leaving so we should work together right
usually happens when people leave you
start working together so most of work i
would stand after francois and he
brought in other people from the
cosmology physics center
and uzuk was also this tripod um
postdoc
and then chandan has been working with
jamie on this uh intermission learning
so
jamie and shannon did wonderful work but
i was not scientific i always want to do
something scientific so i said let's do
something and see really our method
works or not in this scientific problem
so this is uh
simulation data
and try to simulate from big bang
words can correct me who now have
cosmologists there
that this parameter
lambda m
is really the fraction of
spaces that is occupied by some mass
and then you simulate it with
forward and you see the map of mass in
the universe right something called
gravitational lens
and you want to inverse estimate so you
know the truth and the
simulation was done for different omegas
and also other parameters
and deep learning worked the best in
terms of recovering this omega m okay
that's what francoise work
so we came in say that
can we interview deep learning
and remember we said our advantage our
method was we can look at importance not
just a single pixel
but
blocks of pixels
and that can also be generalized to
if you transform into free space we can
also give importance
because free domain is very very
important for physicists and and
cosmologists
and
so we start looking at the importance
the lower panel is the free domain of
the original image which is simulated by
supposed to be the data
and
we look at the score for these different
frequencies and we see that around point
three
seem to have the high most important so
this really indicates that this model
deep learning model pay most attention
to around frequency pump three and that
made sense to
cosmologists and then the high
frequencies
matter less possibly they can take
advantage of that in their simulations
so put less emphasis on the high
frequency simulation
and this is just a tough example to
compare with other
interpretation measures this is the
simplest possible you have one
thresholded
y
and you want to use a different
interpretation to find it and you can
see that from the different runs
our cd gives almost a hundred percent
accuracy and the other it's pretty good
but there's a job of four or five
percent okay this is just a proof of
concept
the
validation really comes from
the frequency
interpretation we came out with
uh was really
coincided with the
physicist or cosmologist's intuition
from physics
and then independently i said i used to
work on wavelengths 20 years ago i said
let's do wavelets i'm trying to really
make deep learning interval one thing is
to make it more rigid than i'll call
octopus like kind of very very flappy
and francois actually
already also independent talk to um
chandan and uzuk about using wavelets
actually i didn't know that there was
already work using fixed favorites to do
this problem
so that's here the relevance is the key
right
an interpretation model is relevant if
it provides insight for a particular
scientific audience into a chosen
scientific problem that's what i defined
it and scientific insight how to respond
to facts about the real world
and the information to provide it and
vape is a local transform
so it's interpretable scientists it was
the nurse referees one of them we have
to convince that person that wavelet is
pretty interpretable it's a different
community
so here's the work and you already heard
wusuke and chandan who also helped me
greatly with
the slides and the result i'll show you
with the geometry
and francois and then uh goggle the last
person is actually apology
in the uh
advanced bio imaging center at berkeley
we're working with him on a cell biology
problem so we took the method and
used up a completely different problem
also got really good results
not just interpreted i like to got
better prediction results
so distillation started
actually there was an earlier paper
actually referenced by rich
corona at all earlier than the hinton
paper it's really you have this complex
black box model
deep learning
can you do steel to make it more
integrable so people have been trying to
use smaller
simpler deep learning model as a student
and the teacher is you use the 50 deep
learning to give you data so you have
infinite amounts of data
and can you now summarize it in a
smaller deep learning models
and people have also done
using star wars deep learning model and
go to a self-decision tree that's the
thrust and hinton
and also editor models which use a lot
of institutes so you can take
the 50 different animal with advantage
all this
computation advantage of
stochastic gradient descent in high
dimensional space and take the surface
and then
kind of smooth version your original
data
and then you can try to fit it into a
simpler model and we chose wavelets
because that's
from free transform the adaptive
wavelength it seems very natural to me
and two friends one
so we set our goal
to learn a wavelet transform
we want to improve interval ability
improve compression and also prediction
efficiency
so this is one page
uh summary of what really does time
series
is telling the time and frequency domain
vertically and free domain fully
transform is tiling the time and
frequency space
horizontally and wavelet is tiling two
together so put different emphasis on
different frequencies high frequency you
have bigger intervals and low frequency
you have finer intervals because we
think a lot of the structure are in low
frequencies
and there are many great books malad
1989 mayor
about 20 years old 25 years ago that was
really
very nice
research area from applied math
statistics and signal processing many
people were working on this i even
worked on it too myself
so here's what we end up doing so we
already have a pre-trained dn for the
cosmology with the model franz fartrain
that was a 18-layer rest net so that's
already given we're not changing
anything
and that was just good enough for the
problem which um
simply you know we didn't go to 150
layers
so that's already given to you
and what we did is suppose you have a
given wavelet transform phi
a plus sign
then orthogonal wavelength transform is
invertible so you can just write x
do the wavelet transform
and then take inversion and call x hat
and then you haven't done anything and
you just put it into
the wavelet however we block
the precise inverse and the fitted
deep learning into one function called
that f
okay
because we're going to learn precise now
precise not known
and we made up this um or divide this a
new loss function the first term
which is reconstruction loss we won't
put sign for say inverse smallest there
it's invertible but if it's not you
still can't have the interpretation
and the wavelet loss is to ensure that
the precise comes from another wavelet
with all the nice uh translation or
dilation
both right if you know a modern wavelet
you know how to do the multi-level uh
analysis
and the interpolation loss is the one
uses defeated deep learning and includes
the precise inverse
and we didn't go to icd because it's
easier to use the gradient base with all
the pi tolerance all the things so we
use this simpler
component wise
um interpretability
okay
so the first term is very clear to you
the last term is pretty clear just
in the transform domain you do this
gradient stuff
and let me expand on the second term
so that's where usual and china did a
great job i basically said let's do
wavelets and francois said let's do
wavelet
and they really went ahead and did
wavelets
so you look at the books
if you have a mother wavelet
right
phi
it's an integral scalable uh scaling
function
and
you have all these conditions
that this
low pass and high pass filters need to
satisfy so we just took this equations
not 7.31 that's hard to turn into a
numerical algorithm
the equations we turn them into
penalties
that's reinforced the wavelet property
and they're more
and we turn them into another penalty
and we collected
most of them
and that's what we made the wavelet loss
function and this is actually the same
if you think about people using uh using
deep learning to pde
to sell pde in the beginning i was like
well how do you do that and people have
done that same idea right pde
you put in the
solution suppose it's characterized by
deep learning
just make the difference and do square
and minimize that so it's kind of
involving the pde so it's like
inside pretty sport definitely
i didn't think of that one i said let's
do wavelets so usual chandan did a lot
of good ideas inside it just seems
obvious
okay
so that's what we end up doing right
we're just doing derivative because um
acd is too complicated computationally
to do
so this is
just a simulation study
you can see that
this is not the convex loss function so
if you start from something like a
wavelet
a noise it converts pretty well
but if you start random noise
you have to run the first two terms a
little bit to get something close to
wavelets
and then you can use the third term and
then things will converge but if you
don't do that thing can go wacky
and this is just show that we basically
can recover the ground truth
with this
same koi
and dv db stability right koi kaufman
this is famous and kind of conventional
vivid minor wavelets
okay back to the uh
cosmology problem
already in the literature
um people already start
already use fixed wavelet db5
something robust cross is another kind
of wavelength and laplace and they also
have this peak height
that you use a wavelet you count for the
peaks and use the peak heights
to do some multivariate gaussian
distribution and because you simulate
you know the parameters and you see
which one is closed
from the simulated and therefore you
recover the omega m
so our result
this is a prediction error
o
mean square arrow point
basically 1.0
and rest that is the closest 1.1
if you use wavelet's different form the
best is 1.25
and if you use our loss function without
the interpretation loss that means
without using the deep learning you
don't do as well you get 1.3 so this
says that deep learning is helping
and we even compare with the best rest
net we have 10 improvement so this is
not just
give you interpretation
but also improve prediction performance
so the original
resonant didn't have enough
recognization or didn't have enough to
write regulation recognization you you
need i would call analytical match
of your penalty of your method with the
underlying structure i think deep
learning probably is not respecting but
the wavelets
is respecting that
and the compression ratio would define
that just look at all the coefficients
larger than ten minus three why we take
that if you just chop everything off at
ten minus three you basically have
reconstruction
we don't compress more just a tiny bit
so here it's really saying that it's
almost as sparse as
db5
but we get better prediction proponents
so let's
this is just the peak counting method we
just took from the literature people
using fixed wavelets
and this is because remember we have two
penalties one wavelet by interpretation
and this is you see that there's a
trade-off right we end up hitting here
and
so this is
a symmetric one not a symmetric one
and this is kind of corresponding to
different symmetry region space with
large densities and surrounding content
information about predicting so this is
reason this is capture some striking the
data that's good for predicting omega m
and the reconstruction laws like
0.089
and the wavelet.one five so you can see
the construction of still dominant the
wavelet loss
so this is a geometric power this is a
geometry uh workshop i didn't have
sampling but uh
this is not in the paper so the the
adaptive wavelengths just got accepted
in the risk
and
this is the low pass
coefficients
and you can see that pretty much with
close to db uh db5 the battery is fine
but for the first
detail low and high pass you can see the
eigenvalue
definitely
lower
for the adaptive values things become
more smart if you look at the scatter
plot the pc directions
even we try to do transparency
you do see the blues
i'm all
on the outside that means it's kind of
specified right there's more big ones
the energy got concentrated in more in
the deputy to make it bigger
and the the last two kind of comparable
your map is something i don't fully
understand but biologists love it it's
very popular so we have a project to
understand what we do this is really try
to keep some similarities
and it doesn't keep global structure
this umap
and you stephanie see differences we
haven't done that but it's like are
these differences we see visually in
umap
is that responsible for to the
prediction performance that to be
investigated
and then if you just take a random
selected image
and you
just look at the coefficients
and you can see that it seems like a
depth wavelet push more things to zero
because this little blue got
higher
and also higher and push also the big
one so it's really specification
here you see a big zero again
big mouse zero but not pushing but first
one you can see it's pushed
more big ones so that's what you want
right you want more zeros and more big
ones
and this is a comparison for
another
selected of randoms like image across
different
levels
and you can see overall that um
the sub bands that um you do have more
um
zeros appearing
this is another select one so can i have
a question yeah so what does lifo mean
in this uh what what does lifo mean oh
level so usually um you have moderate
value this is like low pass this is low
high high low high high oh okay yeah
that's how we tired we did five levels
but the last levels
we didn't really look at it a lot of
noise okay yeah that's what it is
thank you for the question
and if you look at the p-con so we do
another feature extraction use the p-con
that came from cosmology
you definitely see a big difference
between the adaptive wavelets and db5
now our conjecture this is probably
responsible for the improved performance
but we need to do more investigation
which is still this just came this
morning
so uh
we're in the middle of doing this
so that's you can see a huge difference
because the pig count is already using
cosmology it's a good measure based on
fixed wavelets and if you do adaptive
wavelengths you really see the
difference
so that our conjecture this is the
reason why we do better prediction
they're both pretty concentrated you can
see but in different ways
and the eigen
value you can already tell
this is not really gaussian beta right
so that's why the eigenvalues are
limited
okay so that's what we did with
cosmology
i always like to
cross-validate or external validation or
methodology even we solve one problem
to a completely different problem
so we're working with glaco already for
a couple years for a very different
problem called molecular partner problem
so
this is really cool biology which i
didn't know until get on the project
i always thought the cells things get
into cells through iron channels
that's one way actually something else
called classroom mediated endocytosis
so this is the cell membranes
a lot of the food is got
into the cell through this process
so the cargo from outside gather
and there's little guys
molecules start lining up
inside
and create a pit
and then there's something called
citizen proteins cut it you get things
in
so it's really cool
and it's a key process in vascular
trafficking that transfer wide range of
cargo molecules from cell surface to the
interior
but this process doesn't always complete
sometimes just doesn't the car doesn't
happen so it didn't happen
so for cell biologists it's very
important
to know when this they call this
c
endocytosis
is completed
and this is one of the important
molecular
partner problem because
my molecules work together so the
biologists want to know who work with
what
so clustering
is easier to observe it's
it needs it but classroom is not enough
to ensure that the cargo gets
transported
there's something called oxaline is the
green stuff
that is small indication that
the cargo
got inside the cell
but it's harder to observe therefore the
prediction can we use clustering to
predict
the auxilian
and to predict basically whether the
event is completed
and the original data is video this is
kind of nano scale
and because this is already inside like
like the smaller than the size of the
cell
but um
directly using deep learning on this
audio
we couldn't make it work
so i have to track use a lot of
knowledge about
electronic
microscopy
to track
this
like flashes of important signals and
make a time series and then we use the
lstm so the video
we couldn't make it work and the problem
the best method i know about um deep
learning and video still using you know
videos as static images so it's not the
best way to do it
okay so
in the beginning we did a lot of hunting
features because we didn't have enough
data eventually had a lot of data we now
use lstm it's kind of recurring network
with time series
and use exactly the same method we
distill that into such wavelets and then
we use
five scales six largest coefficients and
we did the linear prediction of the
magnitude of the exhaust signal so
that's why our square want to be large
is the proportion variance that's
explained by the model this is a
continuous
problem
again aw did
better much better
than wavelets that's the best fiblets
0.2 this 0.26 the bigger the better here
so this is only explained 20 this is 26
lstm is like 24 so we did a little
better
and if you don't use the um
interpretation laws that means you don't
use lstm
you
have
about um how to say
10 something a drop
so it's really kind of
combining the wavelets with lcm through
the interpretation loss really gave the
gain we both have the interpretation and
also the predictive
accuracy increase
and for this
if you cut at 10.3 again
awd is making definitely a lot faster
from 70 to 57
so this means it's a better fit almost
like for this problem in terms of
compression
and this is just the same plot right so
this is asymmetric
really capture what we know already by
staring at a lot of images you need the
high jump
and the drop that's a very good
indication of a complete or successful
event if you see this rise and jump and
drop of clustering
that's a good indication that the event
will be complete
so here
we have better reconstruction loss
before i was like oh eight nine is o2
and
wavelet loss it's even better so that
means
we really got very close to a real
wavelet
so the same plot right again
the second
low pass high pass you see a drop of
eighteen values
and
you can see that again the blue ones are
out
outside that means more energy got
packed into
the high coefficient under the adaptive
wavelets than the original one
and
remember the other one the cosmology is
like a gaussian this is definitely have
shapes
and
this is
the
let's see
and this is kind of
approximate one two one two yeah
oh this is our yeah this is one two
now we look at the ones three to look a
little deeper into the coefficient you
still see that
uh
very different shapes so they're
different and mostly
the blue ones seem to be on the outskirt
that means
energy packing is better
this is the same um i don't fully
understand what it does because
it's very non-linear but still you see a
very
so next step we need to do is to label
this to see whether a lot of this is
this is from different images whether
this is from one class that's from the
other
but again
you see a big difference in these low
pass coefficients
oh no sorry this is not low pass this is
just umap which um
it's good to visualize but we'll have to
respond
map that back to something we can trust
and this is randomly selected time
series right remember we extracted from
video a time series for clustering and
this is much much more clear than the
cosmology product you packed energy to
the big coefficients and you put more
into zero
much much more clearer than the first
one and we also have bigger increase and
similarly here
at all levels we seem to see the blue
more outskirts and normal zeros so this
packing is not more efficient and we see
that also in the compression ratio
this is the same thing uh
you see the packing
and some that ask
the mole
this is for another random selected
point
okay
um what do i have time
okay great
so what i have done is that we define a
general framework define interpretation
learning predictability descriptive
accuracy
and also relevance so we want to know
for what and for whom and with reality
checks through predictive accuracy and
we organize these scores
for importance not just for individual
features but also for groups of features
and in a hierarchical way as acd
and this awd is very much a
collaboration with scientists right so
it's now it was not
developing isolation after we did the
wavelength we went back to a lot of
methods already um especially for the
cosmology people already use fixed
wavelets for pig counting we just change
one step and we use deep learning so
it's very much
i'll say integrated with uh
the scientific methods not just
we do this and you apply
and all the papers
we had a review paper somebody was
organizing uh
a book on interpro machine learning or
explainable ai
and all the papers if you want one paper
that's a good paper to look at but we
don't have the plots because this is
just done the last couple of days
so looking
into the future as i said we need to
relate the geometry the different
clusters back to the prediction
performance is that
explained by this different classroom
behavior
and would be nice to go beyond
one layer i think a lot of problems
one layer might be enough there's a lot
of scientific physical science problems
and my last group already been pushing
schedule transform and we can definitely
do adaptive in that framework
but we also think that probably you need
to go beyond wavelets for higher levels
they're not really edge detections
can we really bring closer to deep
learning
and also the pd i mentioned earlier
that's also of interest
thank you
thank you
thank you for a great talk
let's take a question questions we have
enough time to
shuffle
it's kind of beyond
uh it's
it's not really related but it's related
to this idea of working with scientists
and i'm curious because i know you've
done a lot of that so in physics right
there they propose models theoretical
models and they do experiments and
sometimes the experiment
doesn't correspond to the model then i
guess
you're supposed to tweak the model
um
and so forth it's like your model is
incorrect or maybe you try to repeat the
experiment you know again and again it's
quite expensive and all that so so i'm
curious if this idea of um correlation
between model and experiments has been
um considered so in other words a model
may not be perfect
uh is there some way to measure how good
it is
or to talk about a measure of um of how
good it is it's very much against i
guess the spirit physics spirit where
you find the right model but i'm not
even sure you ever do
because it's all
still
another experiment right like from the
model output how do we go back to
experiments
that's right so um so yeah so that's a
great question
so in my genomics work we definitely do
that so what we do we're working with a
cardiologist through the bioha project
we actually screw from stanford
so we'll develop we use e3 random fire
to find ginge interactions and we look
at annotated databases and they do
experiments
so they will knock out
a genes
and to see whether our predictions
actually mean that there's they're
responsible for some heart disease do
you change your model then depending on
the experiments or do you just say yeah
you're really saying that how do we take
that back into account i think it should
be done we haven't done that because
we're still helping them to analyze the
the results
and the previous uh collaboration we had
with susannah kerslav for another
drosophila project
we find the important gene
because it's lisa
but our computation predictions were not
right
so we don't even know
how to bring it back the hope was we did
40 experiments there
and we found one important gene because
the embryo dies at 16th hour
but
our quantitative prediction
said that that's related to this very
famous gap gene network we don't believe
it
but we did find something
so there's this
science is
like if you find something is good
enough but whether you can bring it back
really depends i'm hoping that the
cardiologists will have better chance to
bring that back to our model but we
haven't done that
that's what we hope will be able to do
but
it's a great future direction
and people do a lot of nauka experiment
with the east and things like that right
i think they might have a better chance
because very quick here it's very
expensive we only can knock out one gene
and there's also a problem in general
about this narcotic experiment it's like
are you creating a state nature never
sees
because when you're just so abruptly
knock something out
would you ever see that if nature just
progressed by itself
so that's a pretty
fundamental problem about all these
knock-off experiments so we'll hope to
integrate it back
for example maybe we can eliminate some
interactions we found
we can definitely eliminate maybe some
genes to reduce the search the ideal
i was envisioning was really we work
with the experiment together
not just in a very um
staged fashion but more integrated
but um
so we talked to the experimenters a lot
but right now we're just struggling with
analyzing the narcotic experiments
so
eventually it would be great we do that
but i don't know what analytical form
would take
it's a long answer to her
thank you uh for the answer and uh
actually i have a question oh
okay yeah so maybe i can go first so uh
because the calling for experiments uh
it looks like the coefficient for the
adaptive uh wavelet uh tend to be more
sparse yeah than the question of the db
five yeah the best uh
yeah i wonder do you have any comment on
why the learner quotient for a of d is
more special well we use l1 right in the
interpretability i should have mentioned
that thank you for the question we use
l1 in the interpretation
if we use l2 i don't think you'll have
it okay because in the spirit because
with this to get sparsity right you know
like for compression i see so we did l1
okay yeah thank you for the question yes
that's why we definitely encourage that
but a nice surprise that we also did
better with prediction so that means
there's a matching
yes
uh so i have some
extremely vague confusion but i have
hope that maybe you could help help me
in some way with this so on the one hand
i really like the perspective
oh sure so on the one hand i really like
the perspective on interpretability it
says sort of interpretable for whom yeah
right that uh saying that the algorithm
is interpretable to cosmologists is
different than for the lay public and so
on right
on the other hand
my sense is a lot of the
excitement around
successful methods of machine learning
something like random forests is their
extreme agnosticism right that you can
somehow throw a random forest at a
dataset where you don't know what the
dataset is about at all and it will just
find patterns right
so i guess i i am wondering
uh if if you're trying to
bring interpretability to
uh methods like random force and deep
learning that are somehow supposed to
not be about anything specific if the
interpretability you know does that
require essentially
abandoning these hyper general methods
that sort of don't care what domain of
applications no i think the deep
learning as as shown right i kind of i
think there's a tension between the two
but i think both are needed
because if we didn't if i remove the
interpretation loss which is use used
deep learning my prediction accuracy
actually
decreases
so there's a need to use this powerful
machinery that you can search very
efficiently and follow the pattern in
the data to go to a good place and then
you kind of shrink back i see
so i'm definitely for genomics actually
the decision should have a lot of
biological backing because thresholding
behavior oh interesting so it's already
kind of matching there
but random forest is used for you know
housing
price prediction a lot of other things
so i think that's our off-the-shelf and
you can also have this off-the-shelf
kind of intermediate method that's what
i said like
like you want in general decision trees
people are happy so so just you
basically define your audience as a
general see so you can also put it under
my relevance kind of a banner saying
that just you have a very big audience
and people agree on decision tree
is pretty integral for a wide range of
people
but if you want to do um
something more scientific i think
there's fruitier stuff it's probably
i don't think people
like cosmology i don't know go for
decision trees
yeah so so you can do both
and sometimes you can
make everybody happy with decision trees
but sometimes you can only make a small
subset happen
thank you yeah thanks for the question
thank you
so any other question
okay so if no more questioning uh let's
thank uh being again for the thank you
[Applause]
so this is the end of our morning
section